oh my God
[Music]
I am always in search of the most
impossible shot imaginable like what's
the perspective that no one has ever
seen before we've done many of these
videos in the past and I think I finally
come up with an answer for the coolest
thing to shoot it out of and that is a
crossbow
crossbow cross yeah here let's see this
thing I don't know man the crossbow is
like a medieval 50 cal okay when those
things hit the scene dude in like 1200s
they were going straight through metal
plate armor steel put this on the end of
a crossbow bolt and we shoot it it'll go
super far yeah and then it'll break well
that's why we just put some padding on
the camera I don't know man I think
that's a great recipe for a lot of
broken cameras but that being said I've
seen you pull off some really insane
builds before so if anyone's gonna do it
I think you can all right well I guess
the next thing to do then is to go buy a
crossbow great and I'll start digging
little camera graves in the backyard
I'll make a whole rope we're not gonna
kill a camera
[Music]
my name is Ren Everett I would like to
buy a crossbow but I don't know where to
start okay well let me show you a couple
all right if this is only an 80 pound
drop because you have a little lever in
the back oh well you have to break it
over oh whoa click it off safety and
pull the tree I can pull out my crossbow
whoa what this one's just a little
heavier interesting we're probably gonna
go with the PSE Coalition Frontier is
this one of the more powerful ones you
have yes this boat has about 175 pound
draw okay that's a lot I take it yeah
most regular compounds are going to be
around 80 pounds so we're dealing with a
lot more poundage so how strong are
these bolts they're very strong they
shouldn't break you can unscrew the
point actually yes okay I was hoping for
this actually because we'll be putting a
three six camera about this long on the
end of it and it'd be very very front
heavy adding more weight to the front
end of an any Arrow will make the arrow
weaker because it has the more ability
to flex it is possible it might break it
might not it might not I mean I'm
totally okay breaking some bolts here
I'll take it okay okay
okay before we get into the build we
gotta actually test this thing I don't
wanna I wanna shoot some stuff with this
and I also want to compare it to a
classic bow which Nico has right here
what's up everybody I got a 45 pound
Bear Archery recurve right here let's
see how it compares to that crossbow
what is that 135 pound 175 oh my God
yeah it's like a gun yeah this basically
is a gun okay Nico just take a few shots
so we can see the power of a normal bow
all right I'm gonna aim for the top
Circle top Circle all right Circle
[Music]
were you aiming for the bullseye I was
aiming for the circle above it I'm
supposed to say that I mean that looked
like a bow bows are powerful they shoot
things
now does your does your crossbow have
the grace of a bow does it have the
Simplicity of a bow I'll show you I'll
show you Grace
look at how graceful this is
oh
yeah it's a lot of work to shoot a
simple bolt shoot a stick okay so I'm
gonna aim for the hit the right one the
right one yeah the right Circle the
right Circle
damn
wow
Bullseye congratulations
um I did get a bullseye look at that uh
also that thing shoots fast
this thing's got some power considering
how powerful that was
how are you just gonna keep the camera
from just like snapping off the stick if
it shoots out of the crossbow it's
meaning it's accelerating from like zero
to
a thousand instantly
honestly I don't have an answer for that
yet I'm just gonna hope it doesn't die
okay so I grabbed some stuff from the
store I think it's time for us to really
test the power of this crossbow
it blew open the back of the can
[Music]
well I think it's time to blow up some
fruit it's just gonna go right through
the fruit yeah but with the punch tip oh
the punch tip let's see it
oh that thing exploded oh the camera the
camera
[Music]
dude okay now
we gotta figure out how to actually get
a freaking camera on the end of this
okay before we get into the actual build
I feel like I should probably tell you
about the camera we're trying to launch
here because the insta 360 X3 is pretty
freaking sweet and I thought you know
what this is a good opportunity to
practice some one roll tricks so I can
actually show you just how easy it is to
get some sick Clips I hit an all-time
new top speed record I just hit 26 and a
half miles an hour oh my God
I'm not kidding when I say that I think
this is like my favorite insta 360
camera this thing shoots 6K almost it's
like 5.7 k at 30 frames per second it's
got a half inch sensor plus if you don't
want to shoot full 360 you can just use
a single lens mode and kick out flat
MP4s guess the 360 is very good at
stabilizing everything too so no matter
how this thing freaking Turns The
Horizon is always steady one of the
accessories you can get is this really
cool little tripod handle it allows you
to spin the thing for bullet time mode
but this thing just breaks out like that
set it on the ground I don't have to
touch it
so who is this for you know this is like
for the type of person who wants to buy
an action camera maybe you're into
extreme sports and you want to you know
document the sort of stuff you're
learning how to do well I think the X3
is probably one of the best options you
can get more than like even a GoPro and
I'll tell you why
okay now that I've got the footage I'm
going to show you how quick and easy it
is to process the footage on my phone
connecting it to my phone over Bluetooth
and Wi-Fi is pretty quick and easy now
I'm streaming footage directly from the
camera to my phone here and it looks
pretty darn good so the viewfinder
inside the app is like one of the
coolest things being able to actually
use your phone to aim the camera as if
you're aiming in normal camera I don't
know this feels like virtual production
to me the newest feature in the app
called Snap is perhaps my favorite let
me show you why all I have to do is
either tap or hold down the button here
and now it is recording a clip and the
moment I Let Go not only is that clip
like ready to go and I can trim the in
and out points if I want if I hit export
it's done it's just done so I'm
basically just going through and picking
and choosing all the little moments I
like from the whole video and I can
actually export just those clips
together into one video it keeps things
nice clean and easy the app also has a
bunch of other like really cool features
like shot lab which does a bunch of
really interesting animations and visual
effects to your footage without you
having to know how to do effects at all
okay that's actually pretty sweet like
I'm not doing any effects but I'm
getting them I think insta360 has really
taken it upon themselves to figure out
ways to make the experience of using a
360 camera better so if you're
interested in the insta360 X3 click that
link in the description to find out more
[Music]
so what is the plan for shooting a 360
camera out of this well
gotta figure one out luckily the tips of
these bolts and screw so I can hard
Mount the insta360 camera on one we did
get an accessory with this camera which
is this metal case it's machined
aluminum that this camera literally just
like slips into like that goes over the
top here tightens down there's a regular
tripod screw hole here which is actually
a quarter inch wide with 20 threads per
inch so this is how all cameras get
mounted to stuff there's a couple
different types but this is the most
common type of screw that works with a
tripod goes right into the case
perfectly look at this I'm going to
modify this Arrowhead so that I can
mount the 360 camera to it and then
screw that directly into the arrow I've
got a little hole here that I can maybe
tap so that I can put the screw into
tapping is the process of making screw
holes or screws themselves what's really
cool about this process is that it
allows you to turn any hole into a
threaded hole okay let's test this with
an actual screw
so in theory
can you imagine how screwed you'd be if
you got shot with this
what I think I'll probably try to do
next is take a Dremel and cut down the
actual screw here
[Music]
and I'll use some bolts here to get it
tight at the exact angle I need it to be
at so now
in theory
[Music]
so this should finally work
get that in there
yes look at this look at this it's
perfect so they gave us a few cameras to
use one of which is a dummy camera that
doesn't shoot video so we can actually
use it for testing without fear of
breaking it now whether or not the bolt
or the head of the bolt or the screw or
the camera survives firing even once I
guess we'll find out
safety's off
okay ready hopefully this doesn't
explode and cut my face up
uh
uh
oh I didn't
[Music]
where'd it go
it hit the cactus
I was like why is there Cactus inside
the lens
well
okay
this is going to require a little bit
more
effort to design
fix it kind of so instead of using the
tip of the bolt as like sort of the
mounts for the camera I'm just going
straight into the bolt itself no
middleman at all I think this is more
sturdy and I'm hoping this will survive
some tests rolling oh my God Nick
just in case
okay ready safety off
three two one
did it work did it work did it work
oh my god dude the entire insert came
out
Oh weird what bowed out look at that
what the hell how does that happen what
the frick
the problem is that we're exerting way
too much force on these arrows and
they're flexing it's not that it's being
weighed down is that as is pushing it
it's flexing upwards and that's causing
the actual like angle of attack to
change so as it flexes and goes
downwards that caused the whole front of
it to just exit out of the arrow and the
arrow just
petered out I don't know what strength
these bolts are we just need stronger
bolts a lot stronger
we got three bolts here one is thick
carbon fiber the other is aluminum and
the other is a wider carbon fiber bolt
nine millimeters instead of eight I'm
gonna go ahead and start with the pile
driver the bone crushing strength all
right this is the pile driver test
number one of the day
foreign
dude this oh this messed up the case
look at that Yep this definitely just
broke the head off of the the arrow
all right first test with the pile
driver failure
okay this is the aluminum bulk test
number two
[Music]
I did that without my safety glasses on
dang it
Ah that's how you lose an eyes because
of being stupid like me foreign
dude it bent the arrow
that straight up just ripped off of it
good to know aluminum not an option at
all
all right this is the Easton nine
millimeter Bolt
test three of three
there's part of it
foreign
so basically right now I need to figure
out how to buy carbon fiber tubing
or
so if the problem is that the arrows
aren't stiff enough and they're flexing
to the point that they actually break we
need to make them stiffer and so to fix
that I bought some steel rods I didn't
know what rods were going to work so I
just bought a few here and I think I'm
going to use this long threaded Rod this
is essentially just the world's longest
tripod screw I'm going to tap the knock
and I can put the threaded Rod into that
just a little nut put oh my God this is
going to take forever
I have an idea
it's gonna take me so long
[Music]
good thing we had that nut tightener
this would have taken me so long to get
it through all of that I can chop the
end of this off and then we'll have a
working arrow that I can test like right
now
safety off
hey the arrow held together
[Music]
it was a broken case
[Laughter]
will it fired
fire but the arrow drops so much it hit
the bottom of the chair and completely
destroyed the case
and somehow this camera still functions
as a dummy camera this thing is still
alive it's just crazy to me that this
thing is still alive you know what I
think this works well enough I'm going
to use the last case we have here and a
real working camera
I think it's time to actually get a shot
how many chances do we have to get this
today we have two chances because we
have two cameras and two different
arrows one of the arrows I made last
minute this morning and I doubt it will
actually survive but we only have one
camera cage right we do only have one
camera cage
all right here's a good spot this way
we're shooting away from the highway
as I'm probably just gonna shoot it from
like right here straight up just between
these two trees out into the open field
as a first test I want to see how far it
can go without a camera on it they're
saying this thing should be able to go
like seven or eight hundred yards so
maybe we'll get like 20 yards 20 yards
or so 22.
um oh you know what else we gotta do we
have yet to do Titan Mode what is Titan
Mode you know you know Titan Mode
oh no
[Laughter]
just as like a tiny extra layer of
protection I took one of those like foam
tips from like the regular Arrow pack or
whatever and I just like cut it up and
glued it on top here with some E6000 so
it's relatively secure
it just feels so rickety
okay let's get the shot you ready hold
on yep Ready okay
I think it's gonna make it to the 360
camera that's out there I'm gonna kind
of aim for it yeah maybe if it even
makes it out of the crossbow I'm
honestly worried for my phone dude
there's going to be something exploding
nah dude this isn't gonna explode we're
past that all right Ren okay ready
safety off and
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
dude
[Applause]
I don't think it broke dude let's get on
the wheels
I think it's all in one piece written I
think so too it might be bent up a
little bit
look at that okay okay it's like a
little bit thin it's a little bent
but it's still rolling look at that that
was a crazy look how far it went
I stand uh I stand corrected here
it actually worked this is about
comparable with the cannon to be honest
and this is significantly quieter we
didn't come here expecting that this was
going to not break so anything else
after this is just bonus let's just see
what cool shots we can get before we're
uh we're out of a camera
I say we shoot it over these trees now
what are your predictions for how far
it's gonna go like directly this way
over those trees safety glasses on
safety's off
let's get a sick shot
hell yeah
that was such a sick shot oh my God that
was so cool
dude
I went far that went really far and
honestly I don't think this got any more
bent up than it was before
third shot let's go so we got two solid
shots so far and for this last one I
just kind of want to do it
kind of gotta try it I'm gonna shoot it
directly up I want to see how high it
can go now this is very dangerous do not
try this at home do not try any of this
like ever okay this is more or less
straight up
you guys ready
and
[Music]
oh boy
oh boy dude how long was that Airborne
that went really high dude and it was
just like camera right into the ground
I'll be very surprised if this like
survived
oh
look at how it landed wow
it's still rolling yeah it's still
rolling hey let me clean the lens
[Music]
oh my God this thing's a freaking Beast
listen to the dirt I cannot believe this
thing is like still working just fine
this is probably the craziest idea we're
trying yet because I'm trying bullet
mode which shoots at 180 frames per
second looking directly back down the
length of the arrow and so I think we
should try shooting it through the tree
I see a little Gap there
all right this thing's loaded
dude am I gonna have to go into a spider
tree again for you it just leaves all I
see is branches untangled in the
branches no no this is going to go
through I see a slight Gap there that
I'm going to aim for all right you ready
we know it's gonna happen
safety off
knew it dude you went out the other side
what yeah
did you see the arrow because I only saw
the impact
wow I thought it got stuck yeah dude I
am so impressed with this camera like
come on dude it just went through a tree
yeah the arrows seen better days it's
still fine after all those impacts I
think it's time to retire this arrow and
camera I think we got some six shots I
think we got four different shots
dude I am so excited this worked I kind
of doubted it would but you know what it
did you remember when we put the GoPro
inside of the Nerf football and threw it
off a bridge we killed like four GoPros
on that shoot and this thing has
survived significantly more like
velocity I feel like it's all because of
this honestly I didn't think it was
gonna make it past one Landing I thought
it was going to break immediately
the fact that we've gotten a couple
shots now that's just that's awesome man
I'm really glad it worked because we had
literally one arrow that was made
man I still can't believe how well this
works not only did the camera survive
the X3 is only just barely scratched I
mean how crazy is that we have killed
GoPros in the past I think it's safe to
say this is a successfully proven
concept but that means that we now
actually have to apply this somehow how
are we going to use this crossbow camera
rig in an actual production I want to
see your ideas down in the comments
below and we might actually make another
video doing them yeah but for now thanks
for watching please subscribe and I will
see you in the next video